[Música]
bienvenidos a Gimnasia en Norteamérica
es un gusto saludarlos desde Washington
en esta edición hablaremos de la
incapacidad que tiene el Partido
Demócrata y avanzar en su agenda
política causa de una división interna
hablaremos de las promesas incumplidas
del presidente Joe Biden con los
hispanos y las consecuencias electorales
que esto pueda traerle finalmente les
contaremos qué es el fentanilo la
poderosa de adictiva droga sintética que
está empeorando la crisis de muertes por
sobredosis en Estados Unidos
[Música]
promesas principales que hizo en campaña
según la página web políticas la
capacidad para ejecutar su agenda y
resolver problemas coyunturales como la
inflación en la situación migratoria la
retirada de Afganistán y la crisis en la
cadena de suministro entre otras viene
de una división interna de su partido
los demócratas están divididos entre
progresistas y moderados los primeros
tienen una agenda mucho más
redistributiva en la que el gobierno fue
un rol más relevante y algunos incluso
los tildan de socialistas los moderados
son más de centro y apoyan medidas de
libre mercado el choque entre estas dos
corrientes del partido ha dificultado el
trabajo de Bailén después de varios
intentos y negociaciones internas se
aprobó el plan de infraestructura de 1,2
billones de dólares y el plan social que
de 3,5 millones paso a
1,75 billones de dólares una gran
reducción en el presupuesto para la
inversión social educación salud y
cambio climático entre otros derivada de
la falta de apoyo de Senadores moderados
como yo Mancini Christine cinema esta
división en eficacia le pasará factura
en las próximas elecciones al Partido
Demócrata según lo indican recientes
encuestas y predicciones listas
políticos en Whatsapp
la comunidad hispana en Estados Unidos
representa el 19% del total de la
población según el último censo a esta
minoría la más grande en Estados Unidos
por encima incluso del afroamericana yo
Bailén le prometió en sus primeros 100
días de gobierno una reforma migratoria
y revocar varias medidas hostiles de la
administración de Trump contra el
inmigrante hasta el momento estas
palabras no se han traducido en ello
aunque la retórica si el inmigrante sea
menos ofensiva con baile en la práctica
las medidas hostiles contra el
inmigrante siguen en pie por ejemplo el
título 42 un estatuto que puso pronto
sigue permitiendo deportar a cualquier
persona que sea considerada como riesgo
de salud pública por la pandemia medida
que se usa como pretexto para expulsar a
los extranjeros cómo se hacía antes
vaivén está considerando renovar la
medida de esperar en México que obliga a
los inmigrantes a esperar en el sur de
la frontera la decisión de asilo
político tampoco ha cumplido o aclarado
cómo valorar ofrecerles un camino a la
ciudadanía los cerca de 700000 jóvenes
soñadores que fueron traídos por sus
padres a Estados Unidos cuando eran
pequeños y también a los cerca de 11
millones de migrantes indocumentados
al respecto hablamos con Celina Benítez
americana salvadoreña y alcaldesa de una
pequeña ciudad de Maryland con alta
concentración de Centroamérica
un potente opiaceo que producen en
distribuyen legalmente empresas como
Johnson y Johnson y Bowman entre otras
el fentanilo es un opiaceo sintético
entre 80 y 100 veces más potente que la
morfina se receta normalmente como
parche que se adhiere al cuerpo para
reducir el dolor en pacientes con cáncer
terminal pero como cualquier operación
recetado además de ser altamente
adictivo el fentanilo es muy fácil de
producir los vendedores de droga están
mezclándolo con la heroína
metanfetaminas y otras drogas para
reducir costos y generar efectos aún más
fuertes mezcla que ha contribuido a la
cifra récord de muertes por sobredosis y
a la emergencia de salud pública
decretada por el Gobierno de Dios de
Donald Trump es un problema de
drogadicción es mucho más grave que la
cocaína y que logra pocos titulares de
prensa a pesar de los graves efectos que
está generando en la sociedad
estadounidense
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición del asenorte América desde
Washington pueden enviarnos a nuestras
redes sociales comentarios y sugerencias
de temas que les gustaría exploremos en
el programa los invito a seguir con la
programación de France 24 en español
hasta pronto